the business super conference that all
of you need to be at is finally here
tickets have dropped to the original be
friends holders but are now available to
buy I have a link in my bio for the
people that have never bought an nft but
want to come because they've heard that
bust arrives and Deepak Chopra and Steve
Bartley and all these people are
speaking go to
becon.comdm to see what's going on there
but the link in my bio has a site that
we have on vcon that will let you fill
it out and will help you get a ticket to
our super conference May 18th to the
20th in Indianapolis Indiana the
conference is bananas the 50 speakers
I'm about to announce bananas this is
the huge super business pop culture and
Innovation conference I want everybody
in my community to be there so Link in
BIO or click here because the team is
using this in all sorts of formats to
make sure you get to Indy in May for the
super business conference of the Year I
hope to see all of you there